et le vieux continent s'isole le nombre
de contaminés ne cesse d augmenter l
europe a dépassé désormais l'asie en
nombre de décès liés aux combats virus
l'italie compte 475 morts de plus
aujourd'hui un triste record
l'espagne confiant de son côté plus de
13 mille 700 cas et 5 158 morts sur son
territoire épidémie qui aurait pu
d'ailleurs être sous-estimée par
certains responsables politiques de
l'union européenne
c'est l'avis d'ursula von der leyen dans
une interview accordée au journal
allemand bild
elle la présidente de la commission
européenne reconnaît je cite que toutes
ces mesures qu'il y a encore deux
semaines ou trois paraissait
draconiennes devrait être prise à
présent l'europe qui a décidé de fermer
ses frontières extérieures pendant 30
jours aux personnes ne faisons pas
partie des pays membres ursula von der
leyen remercie l'aide d'ailleurs de la
chine dans la gestion de la crise j'ai
parlé aujourd'hui avec le premier
ministre chinois li keqiang nous
convergence sur le fait que la lutte
contre le coronavirus est globale et que
nous devons nous aider dans ces moments
difficiles
la chine n'a pas oublié l'aide que la
commission lui a apporté en janvier
quand elle était le centre de l'épidémie
nous lui avons alors rapidement apporter
plus de 50 tonnes d'équipements de
protection
je me rappelle de ma conversation avec
le premier ministre
à ce moment là aujourd'hui le centre de
la pandémie et chine où nous augmentons
notre production nous convertissons les
lignes de produits production mais cela
demande plusieurs semaines entre temps
nous sommes reconnaissants pour l'aide
reçue de chine
le premier ministre a annoncé que la
chine est prête à fournir 200 mille
masques n 9 5 2 millions de masques
chirurgicaux et 50 mille tests de
dépistage nous les attendons bientôt
notre commissaire et le ministre ch
noir du commerce m en cela en oeuvre
cette aide est très apprécié et nous en
sommes reconnaissants